foreign
Chico what's up Lee
hi Dr John how are you I'm good how are
you
I'm doing good thanks for asking you got
it what's up
uh yeah so I feel like I kind of have a
loaded question here so I'm just going
to put it all out there and then I guess
we can piece it from there there you go
influence of alcohol
um we're high school sweetheart uh and
have been together for 17 years
um my parents died when I was fished
well my parents died when I was 15 and
17. my mom was at 15 my dad was at 17.
geez um
and now being you know 31
I kind of feel like my youth passed me
and uh I've not been able to like
experience other people or myself excuse
me I'm a little like nervous no it's
good you're all good I I'm nervous too
so we'll be nervous together
perfect
um
again I I just I also feel like
emotionally responsible for my husband
especially when he says things like I'd
be lost without you
etc etc
um well on the other hand I finally feel
like I would be okay if all this ended
now
um I used to not want to be alone
because I was abandoned
um but now I'm finally kind of
comfortable with it and uh basically I
just feel guilty for these feelings but
also angry that I didn't get to
experience life and growing up like my
peers
um so obviously there's a lot of layers
to this yeah
thanks for thanks for you've thought
through this have you been in counseling
before
I have I have been in canceling this
your ability to pull this to pull these
apart in that way
um is
suggest you've already done some work on
yourself over the years is that fair
that's fair yeah cool that's awesome
um
where do you want to start
because
um
there's several there's there's some
mechanical stuff there's some failing
stuff there's some norming and some
anger stuff and
then there's just like doing it stuff
where do you want to store do you want
to start
um let's start with who the hell am I
yeah let's start the air I mean
um how old were your parents when they
passed
um my mom was 54 and my dad was 52. okay
I went to add on to this I was adopted
before I was even born you know why not
why not I almost just drop that in there
let's add some more that's it for me
yeah my no my parents are the ones who
raised me but okay that probably has
some identity issues in itself
well it there's a there's a possibility
that you've that your body is highly
attuned
to relationships will get you hurt
and the more weight get puts on to those
relationships the more your body
is trying to protect you is that fair
and so when your husband thinks he is
connecting with you saying
um
you're my everything you saved me you're
the you're the only one for me I can't
breathe without you
um those sound cool when they're in like
song lyrics in hip-hop videos
um for somebody whose body says hey if
you get too close
somebody dies if you get too close
somebody will leave that can on the flip
side that could be torture right
definitely
um
woven through here are you gonna leave
him
no are you done being married to him
no okay and it's okay I mean I'll say
it's okay but it's best to be honest up
front
um
can I just tell you it's okay to be
angry
if I were you I would be so pissed
yeah I'd be pissed at my birth parents
like what what was wrong with me
what was wrong with y'all
I would be pissed at my at My adoptive
parents who clearly loved me and took me
in and then they went and died on me
screw them right and
I would be pissed that I've been with my
high school sweetheart I don't even
kissed anybody else I never made out I
don't know what life was like I just got
this guy right you see what I'm saying
all right your anger and frustration and
and heartbreak all real all good
foreign
you're not crazy you're not like like a
bad person
you're not a bad person wondering I
wonder would have been like to make out
with the other guy on the football team
and I got this Yahoo right that's not a
weird thing right
um you're not broken or weird or strange
have you ever talked about this with
your husband
I have and he doesn't understand we
actually had a couple of conversations
about it and he just
doesn't understand why I would
have those thoughts or you know
I don't know we're Polar Opposites right
I always tell everyone I'm loud and
obnoxious and he's quiet and reserved
except for around me obviously we get
along great
um but I just think we've experienced
this world differently
um and so it's hard for him to
understand where I'm coming from and
obviously it's hard for me to understand
where he's coming from so although we've
had had those conversations we haven't
done like marriage counseling we have
talked about it we just did a big move
so
um who are waiting to get settled and
set up with our jobs and hope and all
that stuff
um there's a lot going on right there's
a lot going on what what precipitated
this call what happened
um
that conversation granted that
conversation was a couple months ago
um I'm also again like really loud I
like outgoing I work for sales so I'm
out with people all the time and like
co-workers and
um
I don't know I feel like I've tended to
put myself in situations where
the question about what it would be like
to be with somebody else could have been
answered
um
and I I don't know if I'm like
subconsciously like putting myself there
or if it just happens or I I don't know
it's probably both in
um I wouldn't surprise me at all that
your body is screaming and yelling and
trying banging every trash can that it
can
um to get you to actually connect with
somebody
and you can put yourself in really
stupid positions to blow up your
marriage and hook up with somebody on a
business trip too
it can be both and
that makes sense
definitely
um
it's real easy to help y'all been
married what seven years
seven years yeah but together for 17.
yeah
um this is this is the season when
um seven to ten years is one of the big
markers
when people start saying oh this is it
this is my life
and they start looking for ways to get
their heart rate back up or in other
words to feel alive and god it feels so
good when somebody who you're attracted
to who think you think's a little bit
funny you think is a little bit silly
um when they recognize you
yeah and when your introverted husband
comes home and
grabs a bush tall boy and puts his feet
up he's a great guy and he's lovely and
he pays the bills and he is kind and he
cares about you but I'm not alive
yeah I just wish we were a little more
alike sometimes
um so what it sounds like here I think
there is a difference between
feelings being understood and being
considered valid
and there is a chance that's not a
chance there's a he he will never
understand
what you went through as a kid even
though y'all were together right I mean
he was with you right he was there
through all of it I mean he skateboarded
to my mother's funeral when his parents
wouldn't take him like he's a great
great guy and I love him he's my best
friend
um which is why I feel so guilty for
feeling the way I do yeah but I don't
think it's about him I think it's about
you
I think you are trying to feel alive
again I don't think you don't like him
but you're chasing aliveness out there
if you think it's something you can go
get instead of something that you become
from the inside out
and so he's not going to understand what
he has to do is consider things valid
and what you're not going to understand
him
but you have to consider his needs and
feelings valid too does that make sense
yes and y'all desperately need
counseling not because I think your
marriage is broken or in trouble or
anything like that I think that you'll
have to come up with new ways of new
language to to speak to one of the new
ways to paint new pictures and
he's going to have to realize that he's
going to have to give on some things to
help you meet your needs
he's gonna have to go dancing and make
out in the hallway somewhere you know
what I'm saying yeah he's gonna have to
come home and you all have kids
no kids okay he's gonna have to come
surprise you at work and pick you up for
a weekend Rendezvous like he's gonna
have he's gonna have to make that a part
of his day the same way some other guys
have to learn how to empty the
dishwasher I need some help here or help
with kids bedtime
um he's gonna have to get over himself
in some of that stuff
okay I don't understand why you need to
go to a hotel and peel the wallpaper off
with I don't care that's you that's you
being open and saying here's what I need
and him saying like I and you say I
don't know why I just want to watch
count on the couch and watch the office
again
like you're gonna have to learn how to
find Intimacy in those moments okay so
it's you all both learning each other's
need language
um what else do you avoid by drinking
because it's not just sex what else is
it
um
I'm not sure like what I'm a
I don't know maybe just
me like I just I
I'm like outgoing and I'll talk to
anybody even without yeah but that's a
that's performance that is a way to keep
people at a distance from you
cause I do it too
this is the pot talking to the kettle
here
you and I can sing and dance and it lets
people feel like dude that we are so
close and that is the way I protect
myself
being outgoing is super fun I get into
some more zany fun situations
but I also have to be careful not to get
myself in dangerous situations
yeah right
definitely because people think oh they
think this is funny and they're allowed
like this
they're probably into this
Fair
and then you think uh what would it be
like to be into this and now we're in a
mess
so what else do you drink from to hide
from what what is it that you're
avoiding when you're initiating sex with
alcohol
um myself feeling uncomfortable I was
also raised in a very religious
background and my body is not my own and
so
I feel like sometimes having alcoholic
allows me
to like express myself whereas
if I'm not drinking or so but like it's
really hard to get in touch with like
that side
so I can imagine
um I mean I was raised in a strict
religious home too I get that sentiment
but you're 31 now and you've been with
this guy for 17 years married for seven
at some point you're choosing to hang on
to that narrative why
foreign
it's not getting me anything
getting you something what is it
control Maybe
the illusion of and that control is
strangling you and your marriage
because there's also the other side
where your husband probably loves
drinking Leah he loves hooking up with
with two drinks Leah and he's asking
himself
what is it about me that
she has to have a few drinks to
want to sleep with me
yeah you know what I mean
um are you is there any chance you're
drinking to be able to do things you
don't normally want to do
you're drinking like if my husband
initiates usually like two times out of
ten I'm like all right let's go but
um
yeah I just I I guess it just gives me a
little
more freedom
to like express it I don't I don't
really know
um I
my guess is and I could be way off my
guess is you also drink when you're on
business trips too because it helps it
helps Grease the wheels of a fun
conversation
and it it might help you at parties to
have one or two drinks sort of pregame a
little bit and then you get there
because you're a little bit more fun and
a little bit louder here's the thing you
like that other version of yourself
is that fair
that's fair it might not be tell me if
I'm wrong
I mean here's what makes it kind of
complicated is
I'm I work in the industry
so all business trips include alcohol
all meetings include my work involves
alcohol you know what I mean yeah it's
everywhere and it's an integrals
part of like my career
um
so the the people I've I've talked to in
the past that have said the exact same
thing you have that they need to have a
couple of drinks before they can
um
have the kind of sex they want to have
with their partner
almost all of them no actually all of
them have said the path out of that was
to first stop drinking
it had less to do with sex and more to
do with I use alcohol for a number of
things
to either become somebody that I think
is a better version of myself or to get
through things that I don't normally
want to do like a party or some like
something sexual that my partner wants
to do that I'm not really into but I'll
I'll drink a couple just I can get
through it for them
um it all comes back to I'm gonna stop
drinking to avoid my life
which then means I gotta deal with my
life
yeah where do I start with that
I'd guess for that one but I know it
um so when it comes to let's let's just
pick sex as an example
the
the choice to enter into
I am going to pick action a b and c I'm
gonna do these things I like them when
we do them I have fun I like being
Reckless and silly
and tonight I'm not going to drink
every step of the way where you feel
uncomfortable or you you feel nervous or
you feel exposed or you feel too
connected for your bodies to feel safe
because it super connection means uh oh
it's about being curious about those
moments and
acknowledging those moments not trying
to avoid them
does that make sense
it will feel very clinical in some ways
um and it would help to be open with
your husband about it like hey this is
what I'm this is what I'm attempting to
do I'm attempting for the first time in
a long time to do life without drinking
and so it may be halfway through I'm
like ah we gotta go for a run all right
and be patient with me whatever
um it might not be and it might be that
you enter into that space and you have a
panic attack
and so it's it's about going there with
somebody you trust and clearly you trust
this guy truly he's he's somebody who's
safe
um my fear is you begin to live in numb
land
in UMB in a numb world
and you begin to
want to drag the fantasy that I what ifs
the questions out of a conversation with
your husband and into reality
and I will tell you with all of my heart
that will not fix the big giant hole
inside of you
it will blow up
everything
yeah
wonder is fun and wonder is cool and
wonder is frustrating and wonders
heartbreaking I wonder if I wonder what
would have been I wonder whatever
um
keeping that a secret will kill you and
going through it will blow up everything
when you said
you wouldn't care if this all ended what
did you mean
well he talks about being numb just kind
of going through the motions that's
where I feel like I'm at
I've been going through these emotions
for so long you know
preparing fast in high school okay
what's the goal finish High School all
right now I gotta go to college okay
College all right now I've got to find a
job get the career okay have the career
all right well uh we've been together
for so long let's get married because
it's the only thing that makes sense if
we're living together okay did that so
now it's like all of those things have
completed check them off the to-do list
if you will and now I'm just stuck here
like 16 years later like what the what
the heck am I doing and again what if it
wasn't like that
and what okay hold on but it is
that what if
is not helpful
because it is
the what if like what if I dated
somebody else what if I those are all
like interesting rabbit Trails the what
if I hadn't have done my life like this
is not helpful the only question there
that's helpful is what is my life going
to look like tomorrow
because that's the only thing you can
toggle that's the only thing you can
adjust
so where do you start
Lee what do you want
I just wouldn't be happy what does that
even mean
I want my what ifs and what if not what
if that's the wrong word to use
I want me considering other people I
want that to be me and my husband
thank you
that makes sense you know what I mean
like it doesn't make sense say it again
I want my relationship with my husband
to be all of those things that I am
looking for in other people like I
wanted to be him but it's not like I
feel like
he's like not trying like anytime we go
out I get all dressed up I do all the
things and you know when I we're talking
about uh sex and coming down to that
like I'm the one who has to like do
everything and I just
I've been doing everything my whole life
for myself or other people for my job
like why can't somebody just do
something for me
now now we're there
all the other conversation was window
dressing
he has been with you and he he
skateboarded your mom's funeral this
guy's been your ride or die for a long
time
and if you've heard
um me quote the great Esther perel most
adults have three to four to five deep
passionate loves in their adult Lifetime
and if they work really hard it's with
the same person
and what
he hasn't realized is that you
have changed
and he hasn't
and
you haven't fully told him
because you don't want to hurt him
and you're afraid he's gonna leave
have you sat down and said not I want
you to this and you never
here's what I need have you sat down and
had that conversation
no okay
I would start that conversation if I'm
you or let me put it this way I have
started this conversation with my wife
with
I haven't been telling you the truth
I have been acting like everything's
okay and it's not and that's not on you
that's on me
I haven't fully spoken my needs out loud
here's what they are
and very clear and then I have to hold
my breath because she might say I'm not
I'm not going dancing with you
I'm not whatever I'm not doing those
things I don't even understand why I
don't need you to understand why I'm
just telling you here's what I need
and
at least in my house
those conversations have been
life-altering
but it started with me being honest for
the first time
so here's my homework assignment for you
okay okay
everything feels out there and in The
Ether
and it also feels very unsexy to tell
him I need you just to pick me up from
work one day and take me dancing I need
you to pick me up one day and just have
already bought concert tickets and let's
just go I need to come home one day and
you're just wearing chaps and nothing
else and I don't know what your things
are right I don't know what it is but it
feels unsexy like he should just read
your mind and know those things that are
going to complete you and it's not fair
he doesn't know
and waiting until you don't get what you
want or that he's not doing what you
have what you had hoped in your
imagination or in your fantasy world
that he was due or comparing him against
your fantasy version of your co-workers
of that good looking guy that makes good
money that's pretty funny that's funny
drunk and he thinks you're hilarious and
he says dude you look good comparing him
to that fantasy of that guy
is not fair
it's just not cool
because your picture of that guy's not
real and you're not being fully honest
with your husband
and so I want you to get a piece of
paper here's your homework I want you to
buy a spiral a piece of paper whatever
it is and be very specific here's what I
need and I think you've heard me say on
the show one of those things for me is
me telling my wife I need you to tell me
sometimes that you're proud of me
because all of the work I'm doing is
just trying to to make youth be
impressed
it was that literal I need you to say
the words I'm proud of you sometimes and
whenever she said them the first few
times I was like oh you're just saying
it because I told you to
but you know what it still felt good
and I had to ask myself why are you
chasing this why are you chasing her
approval
and that was a longer Journey for me to
work through on my own but it starts
with being very very specific
okay
and give him a chance
to become
what you need and by the way you give
yourself a chance to actually be fully
loved 100 because you don't
you hold stuff in because you don't want
to get because the people who have loved
you in the past left you and you don't
want to give it all out because somebody
may leave again
and so you know what I'm gonna actually
cut him off
put my attention over here
and then he'll either leave or I'll have
a reason to go because it's just going
to pile up on the things he's not doing
but he doesn't even know he's supposed
to be doing whatever
you just get into this dance turn the
lights on stop the dance and say here's
what I need from you because I want us
to be what's in my head what I need
right now give them a chance
it'll be one of the biggest risks of
your life
and I would say almost two decades of
being together from the guy that
skateboarded down the street to make
your mom's funeral
to the guy that said I do
I think he's worth that and most
importantly I think you're worth that
stay on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of own your past change your future
I want you to read it through together
and y'all can begin to ask yourself the
scariest question any of us can ask
which is
what do I do now